hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück wir begrüßen euch
heute aus berlin und wir haben heute
besuch von nico hennig oh hallo karin
nico du kommst aus den usa richtig ja
kalifornien kalifornien ich habe mir
heute mal eine frage überlegt für dich
und zwar dachte ich wir machen heute mal
was mit humor aber easy german willst du
die frage wissen ja bitte
und zwar unsere frei ist heute was
denken sie über donald trump ok äußere
ich ein bisschen ja okay dann ging er
los und gucken was die leute hier in
berlin sagen danke
unser thema ist heute donald trump was
halten sie von dem nichts nichts
überhaupt nicht also wenn er wirklich an
die macht kommt dann zwei sich an
amerika idiot für mich ja was denken sie
über donald trump fertig hat das
federgewicht nicht gut nein ich glaube
dass der nicht so ganz zurechnungsfähig
ist
ja und das da die welt ein bisschen aus
dem gleichgewicht geraten würde das ist
meiner meinung nach wenig gesagt aber
wenn er das so durchziehen wie er sagt
dann habe ich richtig schiss verfügen
also ich habe richtig angst wenn es sie
denn finden afrika
aber das ja wie bei uns in deutschland
die afg so ich glaube jemand der ein
bisschen was gelernt hat in der schule
der ein bisschen die augen auf der der
sieht dass donald trump nicht die
zukunft ist und nicht sein kann so
jemand der mit offenen augen durchs
leben geht er wird sehen dass donald
trump nicht die zukunft ist so nicht für
amerika nicht für uns wir hoffen dass er
es nicht will gott mir wird ganz anders
ich hoffe sehr dass er ganz tief
abstürzte denke america zwar würde gerne
wissen was haltet ihr von donald trump
dann geträumt ist für mich ein mensch
der gefährlich zu sein scheint nachdem
was man aus den medien mitbekommt weil
eine meinung vertritt die für mich sehr
extrem ist und jede extreme meinung ist
gefährlich finde ich was denkst du über
donald trump ruhig denke das ist ein
idiot ist absolut also ganz
uneingeschränkt ja
nico bist du dankbar für diese tolle
frage die ich mir ausgedacht habe ja
danke für die frage was denkst du dein
über donald trump er ist ein umdrehen
sagt ja nicht erst zu mir er ist eine
immer man glaub ich ja er ist total
verrückt was denkst du über 1000 rampf
über donald trump ein absoluter trottel
aber die amis haben fast immer trotz
gewählt insofern ein trottel mehr ist
nicht schlimm
was halten sie denn von donald trump
nichts gar nichts
das finde ich wirklich ein schrecklicher
mensch ja ja und was würde passieren
wenn er präsident wäre ja das hoffe ich
doch wirklich dass das kein realität was
denken sie warum ist er so populär
ich weiß nicht amerikaner sind
wahrscheinlich politikmüde und brauchen
jetzt irgend ein ausgleich dafür ich
weiß es nicht also ich bin ziemlich
also besorgt man weiß es noch nicht ob
er das alles so durchsetzen könnte wie
er ankündigt aber ja ich glaube dass der
jetzt im wahlkampf sehr viel populismus
sagt man bei uns redet ein bisschen das
was die leute wollen und schimpft auf
die anderen beleidigt macht und flucht
und
ich glaube nicht dass er präsidial ist
wie man so schön sagt also als präsident
glaube ich da muss ja irgendwann auch im
richtigen moment mal das maul halten und
es wird er wahrscheinlich nicht tun und
da mache ich mir ein bisschen zurück
ich glaube nicht dass er eine land
führen kann
was würde passieren wenn dann schon
präsident wäre
gute frage ich glaube er erwirbt
schlimmer als es ist ich glaube er
verkauft sich gut und er ist einfach nur
ein business mann und glaube nicht dass
der schlimme sachen machen wird aber es
trotzdem schlimm wäre blöd und hummels
hatte echte chancen jetzt wenn jetzt
präsident wäre meiner meinung nach die
einleitung der apokalypse
es wird auf jeden fall schief gehen als
einer der apokalyptischen reiter hast du
denn wirklich so keine ahnung alle
muslime ausweisen so würde das richtig
war mit mexiko wird auf jeden fall
jetzt alles versuchen und was was soll
passieren wenn er präsident wäre so weit
möchte ich gar nicht erst denken wird er
präsident ja oder nein ich will meinen
sagen aber leider würde ich sagen er
will präsident ja klar es wird alles
nicht so heiß gegessen wie es gekocht
wird aber trotzdem ist schon es wird
einem schon angst und bange wenn man es
so hört was da von sich gibt und warum
warum ist donald trump so populär
das verstehe ich auch nicht nein
keine ahnung ich verstehe das nicht
gesagt dass donald trump präsident wird
und danach wird die welt einfach zu
grunde gehen
eine folge drüber ja wirklich ja liebe
leute das war unsere heutige episode zum
thema donald trump was ich jetzt gerne
noch wissen würde micro ist kennst du
jemanden der donald trump wählen wir es
ja leider kenne ich zu viele
was kann man was kann man machen einfach
viele gegen ihn also werbung gegen
michael jackson fan von the polish last
selection symbol und der action campaign
take away passport of a voting von
services und voting
danke fürs zuschauen wenn ihr lust habt
uns unterstützen freuen wir uns
wahnsinnig denn unser projekt ist
tatsächlich durch spenden finanziert das
findet ihr hier unten bei patchen und
hier unten könnt ihr substraten
dankeschön
schreibt uns mal in die kommentare was
ihr denkt über donald trump wir freuen
uns darauf
danke